when's the comedy on
it says if you want my comeback you'll
have to scrape it off your mum's teeth
this is how bad i was at sex the first
time the first time i ever had sex
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm
why'd you be trying to find it don't
wait
[Music]
[ __ ] man it's cool
be prejudiced this summer if i get us
out right now
[ __ ]
but the most annoying one i get is when
i've set up a joke just about through
the punchline and someone goes it's all
invariably it's the same thing so it's
where's ireland where's erlang it's not
my like bet noir it's just a bit
annoying
where's ellen
[Applause]
he's at your house [ __ ] your dad
[Applause]
you've admitted that you're lazy i think
you've read six books in your life
i've read six six what kind of a woman
would be attracted to you do you think
well i have a lot of money
[Applause]
i i don't honestly i i mean he lost a
hat
right yeah and then you responded is it
with a red hat band
yeah i don't none of this makes any
sense
yeah it's a generational thing
i guess so well
what is it now i will tell you what's
cool about the
the internet and being internet
sensation stuff on the youtube now
everybody you know uh uh
i don't know if you remember about but
there's fame uh and did you ever hear
the andy williams quote
in the future everybody will be famous
for 25 minutes yes
i think it was andy warhol
andy williams was moon river oh
and he wrote
[Applause]
well you're jewish that's kevin bacon
what does that got to do with what do
you think your name is
i figured it's bacon and that's the
separate what is this a nazi movie
what's jewish got to do heather tonight
he's black did i make a big thing out of
it
no you're pretty rock and roll and
countdown isn't how would you make this
show kind of more
more kind of cool different host
there's this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board
oh all right do something with that
i i bet the board has spelled b-o-r-e-d
i'm done my cold make you change it
this ain't johnny carson [ __ ]
i look like i [ __ ] a pig do i still
owe you all my money is she annoyed
issue
howard ann are you more interesting than
you look
tell me if there's anything interesting
about your job
absolutely not no it's interesting to me
but i'm sure that it would probably go
right over your head
okay why doris um
doris uh when she missed the question
she took up a a
larger amount of time than necessary
okay you're always very quick are you
hard
in some things yes and other things i
like to uh take my time you know what i
[Applause]
mean
i've absolutely no idea what you mean
somehow i don't doubt that
[Applause]
you go home be [ __ ] up
how's my mama
i beg your pardon
[Applause]
i'll slap you in the mouth with my dick
norm thanks for dressing up sarah listen
man uh
congratulations that's the 100th time
that joke's been done tonight
uh michelle do you know who any of us
are
no i thought uh when i saw you i thought
maybe benedict cumberbatch had gotten in
a terrible accident
you know i watched that casino film i
read the book i watched the film i
thought it was
both very entertaining and you know true
story it's based on the truth it
certainly is yeah
and i looked in the film i haven't found
my aunt since i did it no and i looked
in the film and you're just you're just
barely in the damn thing
thanks dave
now i mean i'm at it throughout the
whole film but of course you didn't see
it was 7.50 and
you don't go for that no of course not
no i am in fact i'll put it to you
another way i carry dinero you think so
oh definitely
i carried dinero and i and i and i tell
you folks very honestly i'm happily
married 30 years but sharon stone
does have the for me
you're saying sharon stone has some kind
of gastrointestinal problem for you
[Applause]
yeah i love lost you know what's last
yeah i'm obsessed with the show yeah
yeah
i'm still watching it i watch it uh i
watch it on the uh
on the link yeah
you got that working on the computer
where you can watch like one edit you
can watch them right after each other so
you don't have there's no cliffhanger
you know
yeah you probably watched a lot six do
you think i'm 80
no you'd probably watch the show though
i did i watch it during so that must be
incredibly frustrating
no it wasn't why would you say that well
because uh
because i couldn't wait uh 30 seconds to
get into it every dvd
sometimes it's better to space things
out though and discuss it with your
friends have a little
talk about what happened and then you
you have to wait a week and it's you
know it's delayed gratification
yeah i guess yeah yeah yeah that's
what's fun about a book club
but uh so your christian background is
is part of the
the show yes and i wanted to talk to you
about jesus afterwards well
not the only reason why i bring it up
but some people thought maybe you went a
little too far
you know as far as what well they
thought that maybe you were being
disrespectful to the christian religion
i'm telling you you need to google oh
good lord so did you feel you would be
disrespectful or just you you were just
having fun with some of
the crucifixes and stuff like that
i don't even know what you i mean we did
maybe two jokes about that
yeah exactly don't you think the
catholic church went a little too far
more so than my cartoon all right listen
a couple of jokes i know this is a
morning show you can't bring up all
those crimes you know what
they just sort of kept moving them
around you know like those killer whales
at sea world after it kills a trainer
they'll then move it up to seattle they
don't give them their background
all right i'm not totally following but
i don't think you know what i'm talking
about
it's a morning show i understand
that kid was missed the graduation and
then it was a feel-good story
and we want to leave if you want to feel
good about america you watch the morning
shows you don't watch this you know
and one joking earlier if that kid's
story about the graduation was late
night that would have been a whole
different story
what do you think he's still missing we
can't find him all we found was his hat
but you watch in the morning it's great
it all worked out he got his own
personal graduation
like i was in such a great mood look how
yellow this couch is it's like the sun
wow thing
where the term kite came from by the way
ah derogatory term for jewish people
i do know where that came from where it
is when that when people used to come
uh over on the uh you know in the ships
on ellis island a lot of people couldn't
write english
so they used to make their mark and the
jews mark was a circle
and uh the circle is called cycle so
that's what
they were just showing it to [ __ ] the
guys here's another kite once they've
seen the
the circle you know where [ __ ] came
from originally
there was some black guy being a [ __ ]
jesus
he was being a real [ __ ] and somebody
said what a [ __ ] and that's where it
started
[ __ ] was a feeling yeah he's just like
this
look at him it wasn't some word
sound that it came out like just the guy
was being such a [ __ ]
that he [ __ ] made someone say the
word
oh my god man we're learning about
derogatory terms and where they came
from right wow
it's history it's a really good history
lesson i never knew